after Susan Carrington is known for
versatile performances in movies like
Thelma & Louise
the Rocky Horror Picture Show and the
client she won an Academy Award for her
role in dead man walking he's played a
number of unforgettable characters over
her five decade career you have to ring
the doorbell but I've got the key you
get anywhere near my client again
without my permission I'm gonna sue you
and the FBI for civil rights violations
I'm gonna file an ethics complaint with
the State Bar's in Louisiana and
Tennessee and I'm gonna haul your sin to
court death is breathing down your neck
you're playing your little man on the
make game are you threatening me you'll
kill me worse I'm gonna steal this
picture right out from under your nose
and you know I can do it
threatening guest stars in the newest
season of Ray Donovan on Showtime a
division of CBS she portrays Sam Winslow
a powerful studio executive she hires
ray Donovan known as the Hollywood fixer
after being blackmailed he wants two
million dollars in your husband's Oscar
I hope you're joking that's what he said
I'll pay him the money but no Oscar that
could be a problem Sam
given the money you can the statue you
got plenty of both I'm not giving that
black million Simon's Oscar what's your
thinking right it's not my Oscar tell
Tom I'll give him three million dollars
now Oscar and a warning to not trifle
with me again understood
I'm not trifle with a understand well I
got to say dirty word let me just start
with this because of those film clips
where do you put Velma and Louie's in
terms of film that you just loved Oh way
up there I had a blast doing that if
only I could have kept one of those cars
I wasn't perfect I I think when we did
it we didn't realize it was gonna be a
call so life yeah how many cars did you
rule yeah it's there were seven all
together and one caught on fire almost
immediately he gave two to his sons why
does the film resonate I think it's
about being authentic
it's about don't settle it was funny
because I got a lot of mail about the
Rocky Horror Show liberating people and
then they said and then when thumbin
Louise came out they left town so
there's somehow connected over the years
what did you look for in terms of role
models for this character in radon oh
wow
actually you know there are a lot of
women that are now having studios but
thank god they're not like her well I
you know it's so liberating to play bad
guys it's so liberating to not have the
burden of sincerity and and I get to
wear jumpsuits all the time I decided
I'm starting a jumpsuit nation I know
and so I was just doing it to have fun I
know Lea I think he's brilliant he he's
he's an actor that thinks of the whole
you know not just his part he he he he
thinks as a director and he has does
more with fewer words than anybody I've
ever worked with in my life and so I
thought it would be just fun you know
and I think that they don't really know
in the beginning exactly what they're
gonna do with you and they told me what
her job was and I did research of course
on women and how they got there and
everything but it's not really about
that I think they have they're both
outsiders I think they have a common
that they both share shame in their
lives she's a loner for reasons I can't
go into doesn't have really a family and
so it's a I think it's more about the
relationship than her job I can't say
what's gonna happen but it's full of
twists and turns and I really just
thought it would be fun and it's turned
out we do a lot of attitude in in the
beginning towards each other you know
you don't quite know where it's going
but then I actually start to you think I
think that it's sexual no I'm not I'm a
good listener I'm not so I never have
sex on the first season the second
season and he's busy with so many other
people but I think I'm going gonna grab
him and somewhere other than somewhere
deeper than just as genitals we'll see
what happens I think that is left to be
we don't really know this is what's
different than going into a film you
really know where you're ending we kind
of know what's gonna happen were you
were you a fan of ray Donovan before
yeah I don't have a TV so I had seen it
on airplanes right and I loved the way
it was filmed and it's so twisted and
all the actors are so good they really
have assembled a group of really strong
strong actors so yeah I was a fan you
don't have a TV but TV has changed
everything though right I mean I just
the shows like this and well there's so
many platforms certainly for women there
seem to be so many better roles there
always have been soap operas where women
were in command of the world but I think
that there's more shows that have these
kind of platforms don't have to appeal
to this massive
demographic that your whole time chose
had to so they can be a little riskier
you saw how many times I'm bleep just in
this tiny little so I think that that's
that's changed and also people can you
know watch things that they save up and
then they binge on watching them all
together you have more control I don't
know I hadn't watched TV in a long time
and then I saw something that just blew
my mind and I was like what oh I've
missed this a lot actually yeah so much
has been happening indeed but thinking
about you you seem to have started at a
place look at Thelma and Louise in terms
that was a movie character but people
identified you with a whole sense of I'm
Susan and I know who I am
and and I'm uncompromising both in your
politics and the way you your lifestyle
has that simply gotten even more so
where you've gone from decade to decade
I think that I've always had a need for
justice that was unexplicable that
started back in the days the late 60s
and 70s when you actually saw on
television what was going on with
Vietnam and with the integration of the
south and I think it became cloudier for
people as you know news changed
corporations became more important but I
don't think I think I've always had that
and I have I have the ability to connect
people with information they're not
getting all the characters I play I mean
I feel very vulnerable when